foreign
he just stole the patrol car just
moments after he's handcuffed and taken
into police custody a suspect Wiggles
his way into the driver's seat of a
squad car and steals the police vehicle
after that he leads police on a
high-speed chase that ends in a fiery
crash you got skis in it
good sticks
it happened in Otero County Colorado on
June 20th that's where officials say 31
year old suspect Anthony Alfonso Sanchez
III had caused multiple crashes
purposely hitting other vehicles dash
camera video shows First Responders
chase after Sanchez and forced his
vehicle to a stop
foreign
body camera video then shows officers
approach Sanchez's vehicle and put him
in handcuffs get your hands up hands up
don't move don't move don't move don't
move
what the fuck
foreign
[Applause]
officials then take Sanchez into custody
and put him in the back seat of a squad
car
shot at me I don't know what the fuck
going on
[Music]
[Applause]
right now
do you have any idea
open your back seat
hey so sit in the car take your shit
first take your shoes off take your
shoes off
put your feet in
[Music]
okay hang your shoe first take your
shoes off
okay
then
[Music]
officials note that a loaded weapon is
found inside Sanchez's vehicle
it was loaded and chambered
coated and chambered
meanwhile in the back seat of the squad
Sanchez appears to begin crying
oh
but seconds later video from inside the
squad shows Sanchez maneuver his body to
move the handcuffs from behind his back
to in front
once the cops are in front of him
Sanchez slides into the driver's seat of
the squad
thank you
with that he takes the wheel and drives
off in the now stolen vehicle
oh
fella he just stole the patrol car dash
camera video shows Sanchez speeding off
even running a red light as officers
yell over the radio
lights are activated
well I have one on algera County magma
we are eastbound 50 from 1 Hunter
I do not have eyes on him there's three
PD Officers in front of me I have two
Charlie three on board
officials quickly note Sanchez has
access to a rifle left behind in the
police vehicle I need as many sets of
stock sticks set up as you can get
there
eastbound about those four two five
we'll find a good spot I notified Powers
they're gonna set up as well
did you get a hold of State Patrol and
find out if this individual is armed
please it's not anymore
well they're my rifle the rifle is in
the vehicle
he was not armed the gun was left in the
vehicle passing the 390. speeds 123.
as Sanchez speeds along the highway
officials work to set up stop sticks to
slow the vehicle Mark's charger is the
one that was stolen I'm in a gray
unmarked marked Charter is driving down
the middle of the lane good stop sticks
out
as many sets as you can get
you Jay first car
eastbound on the West Stone ladies found
on the westbound Lane 393.
coming up on stop sticks
he missed them continuing eastbound
please get a set of stock sticks on this
day
twice Sanchez avoids the stopsticks
Chargers take lead on this we're running
out of fuel
okay
four on primary
did he get him ready to lead vehicle
but it's the third set of Stop Sticks
that finally slow Sanchez to a stop
after crashing head on into a parked
semi
where's the keys
good sticks
body camera video then shows officials
rush to the crash site where the squad
has caught fire
we got a vehicle on fire
Sanchez was removed from the wreck and
taken to the hospital where he later
died of his injuries the semi truck
driver was not injured in the crash
right now it's still under investigation
by the Colorado Bureau of Investigation
reporting for a long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie